[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space today we are talking physics we
are talking light I remember my high
school teacher in physics telling me we
don't know what light is asked
physicists they have no clue and so
we'll talk with bill God was a zone I
patted this off light and gravity and
we'll see what that is it's called the
Rope hypothesis I can't wait to hear
about it bill are you doing today Before
we jump into the physics subjects a few
news for our audience sargon of akkad
on patreon has been banned from patreon
we still don't know why it's probably
that some some people who are opposed to
his politics I've just quoted his
historical jokes and they've collected
for years everything he's been saying
and they've made it look like he was
doing eight speech too bad sargon is
gone from patreon the censorship
continues I also hear that James our sub
is banned from patreon we're still
surviving I can't believe we're
surviving in this context also my book
is going very well it's been there since
three days
it is number one new release in biology
on Amazon but the paperback and the the
electronic version also has reached
number one you release in biology buy it
now leaves those five star reviews it
really helps it helps the algorithm
let's get this book known let's get this
book some exposure it is a book called
the revolutionary phenotype and it is
about the emergence of life and the
dangers of genetic modification humanity
will either read this book or we're all
gonna die bill let's talk about physics
what is physics that's a good question I
think what we the problem we have today
is that we've lost track of what physics
is or what it was
supposed to be and today it's called
mathematical physics if you go to the
university you study you study not
physics you study something called
mathematical physics and I'm saying
mathematics has nothing to do with
physics and physics has nothing to do
with mathematics and that's where people
start throwing the rotten eggs at me and
say are you crazy what do you say you
know and this started really this whole
thing started really in the 17th century
with the so called Scientific Revolution
people such as starting with Galileo and
people like him you know in the early
part and then ending with people like
Christian Huygens and and Newton towards
the end of that century and what they
said look you need to run an experiment
and you need to test the theory ok and
how do they you test it well you test it
doing some kind of experiment and then
you try to apply some kind of math to it
you try to put what you observed in some
form of equation ok and so what has
developed from there after four hundred
years is that today we do everything
with math and people say well that's
science because math is objective right
you have an equation force equals mass
times acceleration
it's a an objective relation right
between these two sides of the equal
sign and so that sounds quite rational
to people people say well yeah that's
that's physics that's science and I'm
saying that has nothing to do with
science that is a description and
science is not describing science is
explaining I have not yet explained
anything and I'll give you a good
example you go to the show ok and you
watch the magician cut the lady in half
ok so he saws her curtains closed
curtains open and the lady is one piece
she paused to the crowd and so you asked
him that mathematician next to you and
you say how did he do that and he
very simple and here the key word is the
word how we talk about a description or
an explanation how and he says oh he
could the lady was in one piece he cut
her into two pieces
he took 20 strokes of the saw he did it
in ten seconds and then she appeared on
the stage in one piece that's what
happened oh I was asking how did he do
the trick that's what I want to know and
that's the difference between math and
physics math can give you quantitative
relationships but it math has no power
or authority to tell you to give you a
physical interpretation to tell you what
happened how it happened what that
caused what the mechanism is and that's
where we separate physics from math well
on that point isn't it possible that you
are a little bit strong Manning the
people who do physics because my feeling
is that most people in physics
understand this of course locally they
may act like math is the thing because
of course the Ikhwan looking at
equations and spits in physics has been
extremely productive it has led to
relativity it has led to frameworks that
I've predicted stuff that we wouldn't
have predicted otherwise I mean from
Newton to and shinin even after with
quantum physics so is it possible that
essentially physicists and and I
understand this we understand that math
is not the final language of the
universe of course I know there's one
TED conference out there were some guy
claims that math is the language of the
universe but the idea is that math is a
representational system that can
actually represent anything potentially
Matt could be made in various ways as to
fit the universe and I think that's our
most scientists approach Matt well this
is the issue the issue is that what I'm
talking about
a physical interpretation okay the math
is okay I have no problem with the math
I don't have any problem with the
equations I'm saying that has nothing to
do with physics physics is a physical
interpret
qualitative explanation of how something
happened what the mechanism was how do
they how does quantum how does
relativity explain things today after
400 years well these are the words they
use they used words such as energy they
used words such as mass they used words
such as field and time and force these
are not physical objects I cannot say
rationally I cannot say I transferred
energy because there is no physical
object called energy I can say I
transferred a dog I had transferred a
rock I transferred a tree those are
objects I cannot say I transferred love
I can transfer a heart but not I cannot
transfer love and that's what they're
saying when they say they transfer
energy or that they move the mass or
that you know the field expanded they
treat these concepts as physical objects
and that's why we don't have a physical
interpretation for the equations I have
no problem the equations I'm saying that
the physical interpretations that they
give are all bogus 150 % of them Surya
was muted so the problem is that
thinking of things like objects it does
bring some assumptions I mean to talk of
objects here you're already talking of a
space in which these objects are
embedded and so not everything in
physics has to be objects because
objects are bound to be a kind of subset
of what the universe is about if we are
to talk about these objects producing
forces on each other then we're really
modeling how these objects interact with
each other in a space with properties of
speed of Newtonian mechanics if we are
to care about how these objects spread
across the universe during the Big Bang
from the Big Bang to here then then we
need relativity and we need these
equations that that bend space-time it
is clear that the reality is that we
invoke in physics must invoke something
else than an hour
check precisely because physics is about
describing the universe in which these
objects can exist as part of a subset of
what can exist
well you said physics is about
describing you also said I mentioned
three statements you just made when was
when at the beginning of your show the
first one you said we don't know what
light is that that doesn't come from me
that comes from your teacher who
apparently was a physics teacher then
you said you need to describe okay and I
don't know what the third one was but
not so important this is the issue the
issue is that let's begin at the
beginning like you know like the Bible
in the beginning do we need a physical
object to do physics can we do physics
without any physical object well in
principle you could have a model that
explains object without referring to
objects as anything else then a
secondary a secondary effect of that
equation and I think that's essentially
what modern physics theories are mass
and the idea of objects is just a
manifestation if you look at quantum
Darwinism for example mass and the
classical physics properties are simply
an emergent property of an underlying
system so yes I would say we can have a
physics that that doesn't specifically
mention objects but where objects and
invisible atoms emerge as the
consequence of the the properties that
we give to lower levels I guess we could
call them lower level objects but they
were not there are not objects in the
sense that they could be seen in the
universe but there are objects of the
encompassing theory
so when quantum Darwinism says all right
there's a competing set of information
systems within the quantum universe and
as a consequence of this competing set
of entities there is an atom emerging
here or a particle emerging here or when
quantum field theory tells you the same
and explains it in terms of the
activation of certain states of certain
fields or certain interactions be
in certain fields I believe that those
are theories that our object less if you
will but that create object in the end I
guess you didn't answer my question so
I'll ask it one more time
there's nothing absolutely nothing in
the universe can we have a phenomenon
occurring without objects first of all
is it happening you can have you can
have systems in which things occur
without objects for example the prime
numbers they they emerge they emerge
from Euclidean geometry yet there is no
object in Euclidean geometry or there is
no object at least at numbers theory I
mean unless you want to call the numbers
objects
what is it object according to you
because that I think ok well I've
assumed that you are bringing object as
physical matter that has mass is that it
no ok what is an object for you then
this is where we start because I say
that definition of the word object
destroys all religion and destroys all
of mathematical physics that's my that's
my argument and I'm saying that in
10,000 years no one has defined the word
object and you absolutely need an object
to do physics you cannot do physics
without an object there's nothing
happening without an object you can
describe and put an equation but but for
a physical occurrence to happen for
something to happen for the moon to have
a hole in it you know because an
asteroid hit it you need objects you
can't have whole you know the hole in
the moon without an object you need an
object to do physics and an object is
not that which has mass it's not that
which we can touch for see it's not that
which has volume an object is that which
has shape another that's what's a shape
yeah so now now just like you said a
number is not shape so I can't use
numbers I need to do physics with shapes
I need to make a movie of my theory of
my explanation for a cause or
second ISM if I have to tell you for
example how a car works
I can I can make a movie of the whole
thing because you can see every part you
can see the gas going through the tube
going to the carburetor going to the
Pistons and so on the car moves forward
you can understand my theory of how a
car works simply by looking at the movie
how can we do this with space time when
the word time is a concept
what are we bending how do we explain
gravity with space-time is space-time
not a physical object what one physical
interpretation is that how can I say
that gravity is the warping of
space-time when we're talking about a
concept can we Bend love and I say
gravity is the bending of love well I
don't take objection to concepts because
the idea of shape relies on the
assumption that there is a physical
space in which this this shape manifests
for example would you say then that that
light or in that in general would you
say that waves would you say that waves
are objects no of course not there's no
such thing as a wave there's no such
thing as space-time that's the point you
need to have something that has shape
and if you look at the transverse wave
that they use in quantum mechanics and
in wave theory what you have is vectors
within a vector is simply an object that
has magnitude and direction so all these
little lines that you see when they show
you this transverse wave those are just
vectors those are mathematical concepts
a wave is not a physical object what the
way no I'm actually willing to follow
you on this line of thought so okay
physics is about shapes this is what
you're saying but it's it's a car it
seems to me like an assumption like you
could be in a universe where other
things matter where the gaps between the
primes matter more than anything and
that is the subject of your physics at
shape is just an emergent property of
any systems of space in which you have
the possibility of having states of yes
or
No so if there is if there is some
plastic at this position in the universe
then of course the emergent property of
that will be shape but that is nothing
else than stating the fact that space
exists couple of examples I'll let you
choose okay you got a choice here
brick goes through the window and breaks
the window and the brick falls on the
floor okay so I come home and say and
ask the person how did the window break
what is he gonna tell me is he gonna say
well there was a force with a lot of
energy and it went and all this mass
went through the window or is he gonna
say look a brick went through the window
and just broke it I mean how do you
explain some do you use concepts such as
force energy and mass to explain a
broken window and is that good that's
the point you could you can say you
could see that there were atoms in the
brick and these atoms they add a
magnetic force that was negative on
their outer shell and this magnetic
force pushed into the atoms of the
window and therefore corrected and
eventually broke it's such that the
atoms of the window were not attached to
each other anymore you couldn't make it
in terms of force the idea is that force
is not is not a mutually exclusive with
the concept of shapes and objects
existing I don't need that if I if I
want to explain how I pull a bucket of
water with a pulley
I say look the book the rope is tied
around the pulley I pulled on the rope
and it lifts the bucket I don't need the
word force I don't need the word energy
I don't need any mathematics to explain
that physical phenomenon I do not need
any mathematics energy I don't need the
word time all I need to show is how I
pulled the bucket up and the same way if
I broke the window I have to explain
look I threw a rock and that's how the
window broke I don't need the word
energy I don't need the word time I
don't need the word mass I don't need
any of the garbage of mathematics but it
does seem that
your use of the word pull there are
assumptions underlying pull the idea of
pulling works if the object is sticking
to itself enough that it remains an
object once you pull it and if you pull
it in the vertical direction then yes
you will be countering some force of
gravity you may not want to call it
first and I'm willing to follow you on
any crazy land on this I'm willing to
explore anything but you're gonna have
to face something that I call gravity
yes
and just one more thing see I can make a
movie I don't have to use the word cool
I can show the they elect the
extra-terrestrial alien right I can show
how I pulled the bucket up I just show
him the movie I said you know I'm cool
here in other words I show the movie of
guy pulling the rope going around the
pulley in the bucket coming up I don't
need the word energy nothing I can't
even put it on the screen all I have to
show is the mechanism and that's what
we're missing with physics today we're
physic no one can tell you it here look
I have a two magnets here can you see
that okay okay and how does how do we do
that magic well there's not a single
person on earth and the last 10,000
years can explain how this magic happens
why because they're using concepts no
one can tell you how a magnet attracts
another no one can tell you how this pen
you know why it falls to the floor the
question that they have to answer is
what physical entity comes in contact
with the skin of the pen otherwise we
don't have an explanation
you cannot say oh it fell because the
mass was attracted by gravity that's not
an explanation an explanation is tell me
what physical object came in contact
with the skin of the pen that's how we
explain it in physics I mean your math
you're totally right on this we don't
have an intimate explanation for gravity
for magnetism we explain these as forces
and we describe these for now we
quantify these so we can say exactly how
much time the pen will take to reach
Dede hurt we can say that it would fall
apparently on a different planet that's
what we know so you're right on this we
don't have a fundamental explanation of
these phenomena in a unified theory of
everything if you will so I'm following
you on this one where does that bring us
okay that brings us to the Rope model
see the rope here's a rope this is a
rope okay and this is a physical object
a wave is not a physical object in fact
a wave is a cross-section of the rope if
you if you take this rope you cut it in
half then you'll see what a wave is and
I'm saying that a rope does give us an
idea of how gravity how liked how
electricity how magnetism work why
because I'm saying that all atoms in the
universe are interconnected whereas
quantum mechanics and mathematical
physics in general say that all
particles are discrete particles they
have nothing you know they're all just
floating around in space and one
particle has nothing to do with the
other particle each one is an individual
Island I'm saying that all atoms in the
universe are interconnected now with
that we can explain action at a distance
because otherwise if we don't have some
kind of elongated object between objects
we cannot explain action at a distance
what are we going to put between two
object let's say here I have two balls
for example look I have two balls right
okay here yeah the new quantum says
quantum says that you know this this
particle can affect this particle from a
distance okay and the question then
becomes are we not going to put
something between these two balls we're
saying this one affects this one but
there's nothing in between them that's
magic that's putting spirits in between
the two balls if instead we have some
kind of rope some kind of elongated
mechanism right now we can explain how
this one affects that one and so I'm
saying that the invisible entities that
are between two magnets which do
entanglement which is how one particle
affects another one at a distance
only be done if you have some kind of
physical mediator and invisible physical
mediator all right so let's say we're
we're looking at planet Earth and we're
looking at the moon planet Earth is
attracting the moon toward itself such
that the moon doesn't go away and there
are various ways in which you could
explain this the Newtonian mechanics was
saying well there's a force there's a
force that pushes the moon toward the
earth quantum physics and voc's a
hypothetical particle which would be the
graviton you are saying the graviton
theory but what do you think about it
that it doesn't make sense that we won't
ever find a graviton yeah of course
because the and here again once I say
here here's the here's the earth let's
see if I get it right this is the earth
okay yep the moon okay now is the
Earth's throwing gravitons particles
added if you throw particles at
something at a dog do you attract them
no you can only push them away
the particles can only when you throw
something when you throw bullets all you
can do is push away something you can
never attract using bullets well that's
it well let me just pause on time to
state that you are bringing an
assumption which is that these particles
work in the same way that Newtonian
particles work by carrying energy
inertia energy and the properties of
speed and now it's transmitted between
objects that collide each other right in
other words if I throw something out
words I cannot bring that whatever it
hits in words I cannot shoot an arrow
and bring the target towards me and
that's yeah those are some shows that
rely on the on state thing that these
particles work like classical objects
that would carry energy in their speed
yeah because otherwise we have to use
what quantum uses which is magic they're
saying we don't understand quantum but
this is how we what we see in the lab
that the particle goes out and attracts
something in words of course
because they have no explanation for it
that's a mathematical thing where they
say we're going to introduce negative
force or negative momentum so yeah so we
throw the particle out that delivers
negative momentum and attracts the
target inwards that's magic that's
that's nonsense obviously it's a it's a
bogus explanation on the other hand if
the gun and the target were the arrow of
the bow I guess the bow in the air and
the target are connected now we can
explain how the bow attracts the target
or how the gun attacks the target
because they have to have some mediator
in there all right I'm interested in
getting there but I just want to take
the defense of my physics friends and
say that in stating the gravity term
they're nothing working magic they're
making a prediction it's like it would
be awesome to find the graviton would
wouldn't you acknowledge that it would
be awesome that someone predicted that
there would be a particle and that we
would eventually find it it's not
necessarily magic it is hypothesis about
what we may find if our calculations are
correct
keep in mind what you're saying you're
saying that you're looking for a
particle again that goes outwards and
pulls something in words how does that
how can you rationalize that that's the
fascinating thing is that we may be
faced with a particle that does carry
negative momentum but I'm not another
stuck on this hypothesis I think it
would be awesome I think that
alternative hypothesis are also awesome
before we move to your rope iPod is this
and how that works there let's just talk
about real that relativity because on
the other end you have quantum physics
saying well it could be a graviton you
also have relativity which says it could
be a curvature of space-time yeah and
can anyone draw that can anyone put make
a movie of how four-dimensional
something whatever that is including
time which is a concept how you can bend
it how do you bend time I mean you
cannot see that in your head because
bending a three-dimensional space is
like impossible in your head but we can
see it
two dimensions and imagine how that
would look like in three dimensions it's
simply mathematics that tell you that no
the universe is not made of squares and
grids that are perfectly aligned like do
you recognize that your iPod does this
relies on this assumption at least that
you are constructing a grid of perfectly
aligned squares that never curve that
never but that never changed your
hypothesis does rely on this assumption
right my assumptions involve all objects
only objects there are 3d objects I do
not use squares I do not use
four-dimensional unimaginable
four-dimensional entities which are
really concepts and that's why we have
to use objects as long as we lose
objects we're doing physics soon as we
use concepts we're not doing physics
anymore you can't bend space-time
because space-time is a concept you
can't send away because a wave is a
concept you can't send a zero
dimensional particle which is actually a
field because those are concepts and so
on down the line the reason they had to
use thing to come up with things like
negative momentum or warpage of
space-time is because they could not
give a rational explanation they had to
use concepts with concepts you can do
anything you can say yeah love moves
mountains yeah go try it I mean make the
movie of love moving Mountain what
you're gonna put for love and what are
you gonna put for a negative momentum
well I mean how do i how do I make a
movie with negative momentum I just make
it by magic wand well it seems that your
energy did convince some people on the
chat because they are saying jf is an
Einstein [ __ ] all right I don't mind
being insulted I have an Einstein [ __ ] I
don't think that Einstein's relativity
necessarily is the final words of
physics but I think that I mean do you
recognize that it predicts for example I
hear often that it predicts the
trajectory of mercury better than
Newtonian mechanics we don't give a damn
about it because predictions are not
part of science science rational
explanations prediction has to do
future science we do not predict that's
part of the mathematical world why
because they say look here's an equation
and with this equation I can predict you
know I can apply it over and over and
again in the future we don't care about
that that's got nothing to do with
science sciences explain what happened
it's always in the past you got explain
a phenomenon and what these people have
done is introduce the word prediction
which has nothing to do with science
that's the issue so we don't care if I'm
science equation predicts better the you
know the revolution of mercury around
the Sun better than Newton's it's got
nothing to do with science absolutely
nothing to do with saying since you got
explain why mercury doesn't fly it out
of the solar system that's what they
need to explain and if they're gonna say
look it's a space-time the warpage of
space-time well what is space-time
please draw it on the board and then you
say no I'll give you a two-dimensional
version of it well then they're cheating
now they're just cheating they're saying
look I want you to think about this this
way let me explain it no I don't want
you to explain I don't want you to think
I want you to draw it if you can draw a
space line then I'll accept that
otherwise it doesn't belong to physics
there's no four dimensional object in
the universe
this is madness of the mathematicians
who had to use four coordinates which
they call dimensions they're coordinates
and they're saying look we can locate a
point within space-time with four
coordinates and now they start bending
the coordinates which is a concept
they're saying look if we Bend these
coordinates we got gravity that's what
they're doing and that's because they
cannot rationally explain with their
equations how the universe works that's
why they have to invent all this
nonsense I mean under one hour I welcome
this challenge and I think that we are
correct in questioning all right the
relativity doesn't tell us everything so
we're missing something and so I'm
totally open to explorations that being
said I will point out that you mentioned
a 3d universe in your model well 3d is
like saying three dimensions this
implies a certain special spreading so
your words the
semantics that you use they imply
mathematics they imply the mathematics
of maps in 2d and 3d space and
eventually they form a universe that is
very much like what you would have in
quantum field theory is is there at the
fundamental level a difference between
what you say and quantum field theory
any similarity at all quantum mechanics
is is based exclusively on discrete
particles the particles are not
particles the particles are not what
anyone any normal rational human being
understands by the word particle they're
not corpuscles which is what Newton
thought about particles they are fields
and a field is a concept and a concept
invented by Michael Faraday it's a
concept that means a region around an
object it's a region of values of
numbers followed by units that's what I
feel is there is no physical standalone
object called a field like there is no
standalone object called a wave the
water waves the flag waves that's the
object but it does is wave and it
likewise you know with a particle if a
particle is a field then we don't have
anything in front of us there's nothing
there there's just values and that's all
math and again it's because the
mathematicians have taken over you know
since the 17th century
they took over physics called it
mathematical physics and all they do is
math and that's what they fed us in high
school and college for centuries now and
people just started learning this stuff
and saying oh science is math math is
science physics is math math is busy
no-one has nothing to do with the other
because math only describes physics
explains physics has to do with
qualitative explanations physic has to
do with mechanisms and causes that's the
difference between math and physics and
until we get that I do we see eye to eye
Anathem you know we're talking past each
other yeah I think that it burns down to
our original disagreement that physics
must be about objects I don't know where
that comes from but I'm willing to you
to follow the path here oh yeah yeah
yeah but
our can compel me to want to see objects
everywhere to me object is of essence a
very abstract term object can mean a lot
of things I mean we can use it in the
context where it means a physical object
physical matter but object also in its
more general semantics meaning it means
things that and that people can observe
it's like an object of a theory can be
something that the theory is about if my
theory for example is about prime
numbers I could construct a series of
mathematical equations that say well the
number seven will appear here and its
prime we could say that the number seven
is the object of my theory so I guess I
would ask you again I know that you did
already but how do you define objects
well again let me tell you what the
problem with what you just said is so
that I clarify that first and and what
it is is that we have ordinary speech
and we have scientific language and
people tend to bring the words of
ordinary speech definitions of ordinary
speech into science and they don't
realize how important the word is and
I'm saying if physics requires an object
which I do you have to define what an
object is and I'm saying an object is
not that which has you know can move an
object is not that which has volume mass
not that which we can touch or see those
are definitions of ordinary speech in
physics we defied its define the word
object very stringently very very
precise and the precision is here an
object is only that which has shape that
includes by the way that includes
two-dimensional objects and
three-dimensional objects
two-dimensional objects are objects that
don't exist now we bring the word exist
which has is really as separate is a
separate word okay exists is not the
same as object they're not synonyms so
there you have objects that don't exist
which are two-dimensional objects you
know Bugs Bunny
Superman pry bars those
but they are objects because they have
shaped then you have objects that you
know that are three-dimensional a table
a dog a tree and those are objects that
can exist not necessarily will exist
because the one out the table I'm
thinking about does not exist so there's
a difference and for exists we have to
include the word location but that's a
separate issue the point here is an
object is that which has shape and
mathematical physics does not provide
any object any whatsoever for any
invisible entity any wave is not an
object a space-time is not an object a
black hole is not an object because it's
a zero dimensional singularity it's all
mass and no matter and what else
space-time is not enough and so none of
those qualify as objects for the
purposes of physics they qualify as
objects for the purposes of ordinary
speech and mathematics but now for a
physics physics requires shapes I have
to be able to make a movie of my theory
to explain a mechanism so that you
understand it now that you believe it so
that you understand it I mean if we were
to take the black hole example and I
would tell you black holes of shape
they're just not distinct entirety that
is invoked in relativity black hole I
have a shape in that they are objects
that have a structure whereby they will
hide a certain amount of light and they
will let a certain amount of light pass
at a certain distance from them isn't
that a shame no shape means it's got a
hat I should be able to draw it I cannot
draw a zero dimensional singularity
remember what a black hole is or how its
form you have a star three dimensional
star right that's the starting point
it's so big that it crunches crunches
and crunches it compresses all matter
out of existence all manner there's no
more matter inside a black hole all you
have is the word mass which is a concept
and all you have is a singularity and
what is the singularity some
mathematical singularity and then has no
dimensions no volume you have all this
mass concentrated
in zero volume that's not a physical
logic that's the definition of nothing I
mean at this point I'm wondering do you
believe in spaghettification I'm sorry
and what spaghettification do you know
that phenomena where bad things get
stretched as they get closer to a black
hole these are these are euphemisms
these are figures of speeds that are
introduced because again when you say
what is the spaghetti and they'll say
it's a one-dimensional line or whatever
you say hold it you know there's no such
thing as a one-dimensional anything I
cannot draw one dimensional anything as
soon as I put the pen on the paper or
the chalk on the board I already have at
least two dimensions
no one can draw a zero dimensional or a
two dimension or one dimensional
anything a one dimensional line a zero
dimensional point no one can draw this
those are not words of physics I mean I
almost agreed there at least on certain
points I I certainly agree the thing is
that we don't know exactly what is the
limit of the resolution of the universe
that's how I would phrase it it's like
sometimes we may have objects that are
so small that they are essentially
smaller than the Planck length and
therefore you cannot tell that they have
a dimension on the left or on the right
of them and that would be as far as our
universe allows as being a line or being
a line that is observable from a third
party observer what's your what's your
view on the Planck length well again see
you're introducing first the Planck
length is a mathematical concept that's
that's we're talking about length length
is a concept the second one is what you
just said you know you're you're putting
an observer you're saying how can i how
can I measure something that's so thin
is it so thin that it becomes
one-dimensional and I'm saying look
everything in the universe from here on
out to the last bit of matter that you
can imagine everything is
three-dimensional there's no such thing
as two dimensions one dimension zero
dimensions four or five six seven eight
twenty six and whatever dimensions
there's only three
dimensions and anything outside of that
is just mathematics and unimaginable now
we can imagine immediately they have to
do it by analogy they say look you want
to visualize four dimension let me
explain it to you now I know what you to
explain I want you to draw it all right
very interesting so essentially your
physics is is like taxicab geometry is
to be Euclidean geometry you start with
an assumption about space and that space
is a constant thing and and it's just
that the way it is and that's how
physics works I'm interested let's get
into the rope I partisans you present
air can you tell us in a nutshell what
is the Rope hypothesis I'm showing
images of your video air we see these
ropes emerging from Athens correct what
I'm saying is an atom is comprised in
this way each one of those ropes that
you see there the red and blue ones
twined around each other I'm saying that
every atom in the universe is connected
to every other atom that means that if
you were to look at any two atoms
they're connected by one of those ropes
as the Rope approaches the surface of
the atom as you head it there the the
ropes fork out one goes into the blue
one there goes into the center of the
atom the red one goes around and forms
the electron shell so what you have is a
star in the center which we call the
proton and it's encapsulated inside this
electron shell that's the hydrogen atom
in a nutshell so they'll write and use
the rope the rope that you invokes are
the the equivalent in your physics of
electromagnets of electromagnetic waves
is that correct yeah because here let me
just really quick okay here's a rope
okay and what I'm saying is if you
torque a rope okay if you torque it I'm
saying that torsion along a rope is what
we call light or electromagnetic waves
or whatever I'm saying that the torsion
moving
long rope is light and one of the things
that you can think about if you take any
rope to take your grandmother's rope
okay and you tie it across from one
place to another you tighten it so as
tight as you can and you put two two
cloaks pins at the each end if you touch
one clothespin you'll see how fast light
is because that's that's how fast the
torsion moves along a rope the other
cloak pin moves almost instantaneously
you you won't even notice how fast it
moves and that's the fastest thing known
to man
no no device nothing that man has ever
invented travels faster than a torsion
wave along a rope a tightrope all right
now you point out that there are in the
way light works there are properties
that are very much rope-like and I found
this fascinating one of them is the fact
that as as wavelengths become longer and
longer periods the speed of the light is
the speed of the light remains constant
and it adjusts its frequency so that the
speed remains constant and that's what a
rope does in the way it is wrapped
around itself I'm saying that James
Maxwell's equation C equals frequency
times wavelength C being the velocity of
light 300,000 kilometers per second is
equal to frequency times wavelength what
are we saying we're saying that if you
increase the frequency you must reduce
the wavelength and vice versa
well that's the equation of a rope you
take a rope and of any length the 1
meter length rope to the 2 strand rope
right tied it or around each other
if you torque it more and more and more
the links become shorter shorter and
shorter and you have more links so we
have more links frequency and the
wavelength has shortened and vice versa
if you untargeted the links become
longer and you have fewer links that's
the equation of a rope that max will
discover C equals frequency times
wavelength all right and it's
interesting out these ropes when you
think about them for the magnetic waves
are they interact with the atoms because
the atom is typically construed as a
positive Center and there's an electron
going around
being around or being there around in
some probabilistic fashion but you're
saying is that at the entry of the atom
essentially it is a division of the two
mechanism with within your rope the
electric mechanism taking one direction
and the magnetic mechanism taking
another is that correct that is correct
the other thing you should keep in mind
and you don't have it there in in motion
but if you look at that picture
imagine that red the red electron shell
that encapsulate s' the proton if that
expands and contracts if that it gets
closer to the center and farther away
from the center there what you produce
there that is the famous quantum jump by
doing soar quantum leap
by doing so it torques the rope and
that's when we create the torsion along
the rope that we call light or
electromagnetic waves so to understand
the quantum leap and I'm not a physicist
I want to remind this to the audience I
am just a fan of everything science to
understand what the quantum leap is it's
kind you construe it as an uncertainty
between where the border is in to the
wave whether it's more in a red region
or a blue region would that be a good
way to understand it well I'm saying
that what you have is this expansion and
contraction see the this thing moves
back and forth by doing so that's the
that's the quantum job it's that's
changing what what quantum says is the
energy levels it falls to a slower
generate energy level by doing so it
emits one link of rope and if you take
all the links around you know for every
atom in the universe around an atom
that's what we call energy you know we
have this energy expanding out of the
atom
okay and what it does is really torch
perché the rope and by torquing the rope
it sends a signal along each rope to
every atom in the universe that's why we
I can see you and you can see me
instantaneously because the Rope
connects us you know simultaneously in
both directions
it's a bi-directional system
as the famous wave in the wave and the
particle there one wave mechanism I can
only shoot particles at you I cannot you
know we do not receive the same particle
at the same time whereas with the rope
by torquing the rope we both see each
other simultaneously okay so that would
explain why a source of light goes in
all direction from a center point which
would be the atoms and everything is not
only that the moon can go anywhere at
once you know there's there's there's a
laser ranging experiment where they put
a mirror on the moon and they should
allegedly shoot light added motor
chromatic light they look that they send
a laser to the moon but the moon moves
the moon is moving at one kilometer per
second around the earth okay so the moon
moves do you think they're gonna send
you no the laser to where the moon is
going to be in one second no they point
the the laser directly at the moon why
because light is already connected to
that mirror to the atom that forms that
mirror and the moon can go anywhere it
was it's never going to get lost because
you know again in the rope it connects
it at all times
you can send anything you want along a
road if you and I are tied with a rope
you can move anywhere you want I can
send you torque signals wherever you are
all right now I'm gonna try wrecking
your brain can these ropes move faster
than the speed of light do you think
that if if I have two atoms and I have
one rotating around the other atoms at
faster than the speed of light with the
rope sustained that kind of speed well
no I'm saying that you cannot travel
faster than the speed of light first of
all and you cannot because first you
know Einstein was pretty much correct on
that and I'm not sure it was his his
idea but the point is that no physical
object in travel at the speed of light
and in you know part of the reason for
that is that imagine you've got the rope
between two atoms okay one atom is
approaching the other atom it cannot go
faster than the torsion along the rope
that
interconnects top so is it correct to
say that when that you are ok let's
let's try laying this out as far as this
theory goes for gravity what is it
saying well what it says a picture is
worth a thousand words I don't know if
you saw the I sent you a picture and of
gravity and really it's worth a thousand
work but let's see if I can explain with
words no there's another one now further
down I think it is ok I don't let me try
to see if I can find it but you can
start explaining essentially is if you
have two objects let's say the earth and
the moon okay you separate the moon from
the earth and you send it to the other
side of the universe well all the atoms
of the Moon are connected to all the
atoms of the earth the further there you
go the farther they are apart
the farther they're apart okay the more
like that picture on the bottom right
there where you have the two little dots
and they're separated by great distances
well then all the ropes come together
they form like a single coaxial and
that's where gravity is very weak as the
two objects approach each other the
ropes begin to fan out because every
atom is connected to every atom of the
other object as they're very close
together like in the bottom picture you
see that the the ropes have completely
widened now they they fanned out
completely and and that's what causes
acceleration of gravity the more an
object is closer to another which is
Newton's equation essentially the more
the roasts fan out and that's what
causes acceleration all right now what
happens with the Sun because in the Sun
the atoms are not are constructed in a
form that we call plasma and I guess
that the the electrons and the protons
are free flowing what happens to the
rope in these circumstances
well the ropes continue to maintain
contact from one atom to another
throughout the universe no matter what
happens inside the Sun you have to
remember that you have like if you take
an atom like
hydrogen it's different in an atom like
in calcium calcium is element number 20
so it's got you can think of calcium as
being 20 at least 20 hydrogen atoms so
each one of those components of the
calcium will have one rope connected to
it you have to think of calcium as many
hydrogen atoms and what I'm saying all
hydrogen atoms are interconnected so
whether you form an atom such as uranium
which is 92 or an atom such as an
element such as calcium or 1 such as
hydrogen it doesn't matter you have to
simply count one row per hydrogen atom
but don't you consider that the Sun is
not made up of atoms and that yes there
may be atoms in the Sun but that the
main part of the the mass of the Sun is
is a boiling form of matter that we call
plasma well remember in this sense I'm
pretty much with quantum theory I'm
saying that inside the atom inside the
Sun we are squashing through pressure
right to pressure we're squashing atoms
and building higher-level elements so
hydrogen turns into helium and so on
down the line to carbon and so on and so
you're compressing matter but when you
do the what you're doing is releasing
the thread you know they're squeezing in
releasing thread and that thread that's
been released that's the so called
energy that we receive here on earth in
the form of high frequency along the
rope so so you are releasing thread
right and you are squashing atoms into
you know into heavier atoms but the
number of rows remains the same nothing
changing the number of ropes now I have
some of the toughest questions I think I
think I'm gonna wreck your brain with
these let me try to frame it correctly
so that I'm reading Wikipedia air all
right what happens if I create matter
through matter creation is there a rope
establishing from the new Adam I've been
creating to all other atoms in the
universe
what do you mean creation you mean
transforming I guess not creating
creating see we have to separate these
words again scientifically people think
that transform and creating is the same
creating means that you create something
something from nothing what God did with
the University he took empty space or
vacuum and turned it into some physical
object that's creation otherwise we have
transformation we form a tree into a
table that's transformation well I'm
looking at matter creation there on
Wikipedia and again not being a
physicist it seems that you can collide
photons and and create matter from it
this is the issue the issue is that
quantum mechanics and general relativity
have become creationist theories in the
case of general relativity we have Big
Bang that from Big Bang they created
matter you know matter was created from
nothing in fact I have here a comment if
you allow me to read it from mr. Stephen
Hawking who died recently and he says
how how the universe came to be in other
words how matter came to be and and and
here this this really underlies my
argument of why we need objects and he
says that the Big Bang itself the
universe is thought to have zero size
there are something like ten million
million million he has a big number
right of particles in the region of the
universe that we can observe were they
they all come from the answer is that in
quantum theory particles can be created
out of energy in the form of
particle/anti-particle pairs and he
continues but that just raises the
question where the energy came from
right okay good the answer is that the
total energy of the universe is exactly
zero the matter in the universe is made
out of positive energy now twice zero is
also 0
thus the universe can double the amount
of positive matter energy and also
double the negative reputation on energy
without violation of conservation of
energy in other words these people the
first thing is that mr. hockey needs to
understand I guess we got arrays there
oh no no I'm still there you may not see
me but I'm there so the first thing we
have to understand energy is a constant
and what what mr. Hawking is saying is
that the universe matter was created out
of a concept that humans created he's
saying it will get energy what is energy
energy is a concept it's an undefined
concept because we have mr. Richard
Fineman who says by the way no one knows
what energy is so we don't know what
energy is because it's not is a
something it's a concept and from this
concept according to mr. Hawking we can
matter came into being self came in
without God you know this was done all
but by itself so they have a creationist
theory and then the quantum has a
creationist theory because they say look
you take two photons you smash them and
you create particles
what are these particles they're virtual
particles they last for a single second
Omega our equations go right and then
they go back into being empty space and
so this is all magic this is not a
rational explanation and what I'm saying
is what these people are saying is a
photon is simply the effect that the
rope has at when it meets an atom you
know if you talk a rope you're still
pushing on the rope and that little
nudge that it gives the atom that's what
they identified as a particle so yeah
we're creating matter if not because
we're creating it but because we're
detecting matter when we hit when we
strike a photon against an atom right
now what happens to the places in the
universe where there's no matter can
canon can these ropes exist could they
exist and be sent to no one because it
seems that in your model there's always
two atoms or two two pieces of matter
that are linked by a rope what about
sending a rope where there is no matter
well you can't send a rope remember the
rope connects two atoms so the rope
doesn't go anywhere the Rope just
torques what I'm saying is that you know
you have wherever you have matter
wherever you have atoms well that atom
is connected to another atom in some
other part of the universe they're all
interconnected but so in a region where
there are no atoms are no ropes in a
region where you know where you have
empty space back to you total vacuum
because face is not a physical object
like it is in mathematics
physics they say they bent space they
bends time you can't spend you can't
bend the vacuum and so they had to turn
they had to convert space into physical
objects that's why they talk about
three-dimensional space and I say that's
irrational space is not
three-dimensional what is three that
matches the object that's face faces
nothing and so I suppose I look I look
at this guy okay I look at the sky at
night and I find a spot that's very very
dark and I zoom on it and and I ensure
that there's really no star in that
direction and I zoom in i zoom in i zoom
and I get to a point where I'm
absolutely sure this is empty space
there you're saying that if I send a ray
of light that way there's no real flight
because there's no rope you got it yeah
there is no you can't see that's why you
can't see it
why can you see the Andromeda galaxy I
mean you can see the Andromeda galaxy
because the entire galaxy has one
coaxial tied to your eye at least but do
you see do you know what they really
need let me put it in this turn in these
terms you need a highway in order to
send a car and what these people are
doing they're saying look we don't have
a highway we just have the car and we're
just gonna send it out there no but you
need a highway and I'm saying the
highway is the rope light goes along
ropes a torsion that moves along the
rope to your eye that's the reason you
can see the Andromeda galaxy it's not
because they're sending little particles
called photons which are not really
particles not corpuscles there are
fields and these fields are also waves
whenever the amount in addition wants it
at his leisure he says well no it's a
wave and that turned into a particle and
it is it a particle no it's a field what
is a field it's just a bunch of numbers
so they don't have any physical object
that at any point I'm saying no there is
a physical object that object is a rope
and and the so-called light is the
torsion what is gravity a whole bunch of
ropes connected from one object to
another that means if we invite cells of
the universe if I stand in space and I
have a ball of light it sends light
everywhere yeah you're telling me that
the either the entire universe is stuck
in a shell of matter that allow
ropes to be sent in all directions or
that there is some spot in which the
light is not emitted there's some areas
where light is not admitted simply
because there's no matter no atoms in
that region like if you take and I I'm
convinced that if you take two galaxies
the region between the galaxies is so
devoid of matter maybe there's some
interstitial gas out there floating
around but in general you can think of
that region as just the void of matter
there are very few atoms comparatively
and yes in that region we can't see
anything between two two galaxies
because there is not enough matter to
see but Arizona can take this statement
of yours and make it violate the
principle of energy energy preservation
so conservation of energy so I'm holding
that ball and I'm in the universe
therefore there are spots where light is
not going and therefore there are spots
where I'm not losing energy
now what if I build a little shell let's
say one kilometre out of that ball I
build a full shell that encompasses the
entire system such that now light can be
emitted at every point your prediction
would be that if energy if conservation
of energy is a thing then there are some
points of light that will be emitting
stronger light suddenly because now
there's more energy to be released
because there there are I'm sorry in the
shell there is less energy to be
released on every point because the
energy is more divided across a full
360-degree system whereas in the
universe there were spots where it was
not going let's see if I understand you
girl are you saying there's in your in
your hypothesis in your assumption
you're saying we're assuming that
there's a shell that encompasses all of
matter no what I'm saying is let's think
of an experiment on the one now I have a
ball of light and I'm emitting a certain
amount of light in empty space and it's
going some of it is bumping on galaxies
and there are some places in the
universe where it's not going because
there's no mass now I'm saying do an
experiment in
you do that and then add a shell of
matter maybe one kilometer away from
that bowl a full shell that that that
makes it such that there is mass
everywhere around the ball now suddenly
what I should have is that because the
light is more divided because it's going
in more directions I would have to have
a decrease of the energy released at any
point in space from that ball of light
what you're saying here if there's a bit
of matter out there a shell or whatever
a blob of matter it's made out of atoms
and if it's made out of atoms it's got a
each atom that you have in that shell is
connected to whatever you're reflecting
light off of so if I send if I send
light in other words I send the torsion
not energy because there's no such thing
as energy again until someone defines
the word energy we can't use that word
we can't use the word mass that's
undefined as well so we can only use
objects I'm saying if you send a portion
along a rope in other words you torque
the Rope right it's that signal arrives
at the Andromeda galaxy which now sense
that same signal to another bit of
matter which you've just created there
okay you created some bit of matter made
out of atoms then it's just gonna
receive that signal it's gotta see
receive that reflection of that signal I
want to be clear so I'm going to make a
drawing of it because Aaron's the most
artistic show on the internet we don't
care about taking the time so because I
think you you don't catch my foot
experiment so I have situation one we
will call it one I have the ball of
light
it's semi-thing light and I put it in in
in empty space somewhere in the universe
and there are galaxies air galaxies here
let's label them as gee galaxies here
and there are some spots where light
cannot go because there's no mass this
way there's no rope that can be
established that way would you agree
with that yeah so far so good all right
so therefore if
Aven observer that stands between a
galaxy and this the observer will be
able to quantify that a certain amount
of light at a certain frequency that is
holding in classical physics that is
holding a certain amount of energy that
some light is passing here yeah and of
course I won't be doing the the stupid
version of my hypothesis would be to say
would be to say bill what if an observer
looks at this ray of light this real
flag doesn't exist because there's no
mass air there's no galaxy to be
receiving the rope but the observer by
standing in the way of the light would
obviously be ruining the experiment so
err I'm suggesting a second version of
the experiment in which I have the same
source of light with the same amount of
watts let's say that that it was powered
by 120 watt apparatus of some kind so I
have the same amount of watts it's the
same apparatus but then I took the time
to build a one kilometer wide shell
around this light source is made up of
let's say Rock okay
atoms yeah atoms absolutely now I have
the same thing I have this source of
light it's sending light everywhere
however this time there is no spot at
which ropes cannot be established what
I'm telling you is that the prediction
of your model would be that therefore
the rays of light that I detect here
would be lower energy why would they
with the lower energy because the same
source of light air is sending two more
directions than it was in situation
number one well sending in more
directions it's sending to the atom
that's building the shell in other words
yeah each rope sends its own little
torsion so it depends on how many atoms
you've got in that shell you know went
from from one atom in the source to the
atom in the shell it sends a longer rope
as a given signal nothing changes in de
so-called energy
but again we need to know what this word
energy means until then nobody can use
the word energy all right well I think
I'll leave it there and I will let our
audience maybe come in the comment
section and tell me what do you think
would happen would you predict the
energetic measurement in my experiments
to change or not to change those are all
interesting considerations
now before we think we can look at the
reactions of the crowd Andrew Jason's
twenty bucks he says I was just going to
ask about gravitons thanks jf then
wingate says Jeff I'm celebrating my
10-year anniversary with my husband
today he introduced me to your show and
book please wish him happy anniversary
wish I wish your husband happy
anniversary I'm happy that you guys are
in a 10-year marriage that's about ten
times the duration that my marriages
survive I was I was talking about this
with Bill before this show it was like
you've been married three times Jay yes
I have not found my own way to build a
shell one-kilometer around the woman so
that she would stay at the center point
and preserve energy with me not jf says
but what if a concept makes us able to
predict an outcome that is a question to
Bill so what if if the concept helps us
predict stuff it is a scientifically
valid concept to some extent isn't it no
no because again we don't do predictions
in science that's in mathematics in the
religion of mathematical physics they do
predictions and they brainwash the world
after so many centuries that predictions
are an important part of science no
predictions are important part maybe of
technology which again has nothing to do
with science science is only about
explaining a phenomena we do not do
predictions
it's a astrologers who do predictions
all right one day father-in-law j30
they're executed Andrew J says
motion is a concept itself that you
believe motion doesn't exist and I think
you have a video about this bill well we
have to look at the word exists because
the word exists people don't never
defined it no one in 10,000 years
defined what it just means that's why
people talk about the existence of God
or the non-existence of God because they
never defined the word exists and I did
define the word exists because physics
is the science of existence physics
studies only that which exists all right
mechanism so to say that motion exists
is wrong that's okay in ordinary speech
in science we cannot say that motion
exists only objects may exist in physics
in so concepts do not exist love does
not exist motion does not exist
space-time does not exist
black holes don't exist because none of
those are physical objects only objects
may be said to exist an object that has
location is an object that exists all
right so my claim is that wants to exist
oh he can he has to first be an object
he cannot be a concept he's got a
physical object or is he an abstract
concept is he is he a human with a
little magic wand or is he love is he
intelligence that's concept so God
cannot be both God is either an object
or a concept and then if he's an object
if God wants to exist he's got to have
location there's got to be distance
between my chest and his otherwise he
doesn't exist by definition all right
and Roger says no Mekhi meniscus says
it's time travel possible in the
religion of mathematics yes but not in
science all right not Jeff says can
build is extend me how much force and
fuel I need to send a rocket into space
it's not a it's not a question of
science yeah it's a it's a pragmatic
question of application in physics we do
not use math and
addicts in physics we have to explain a
phenomena
we have to explain something as simple
of how a farmer pulls on a donkey and
the way you explain is you say you tie a
rope around the donkey's neck and you
pull on it that's how simple physics is
physics is for kids for babies it's
kindergarten stuff 100 the invisible
objects visible it's kid stuff
and credit right until I give you an
example for example let live so that you
understand my frame of mind doesn't mean
you have to agree with me I'm just
saying this is my frame of mind here you
have a farmer pulling on a donkey right
and he pulls you know boom - he's
pulling on the donkey and the donkey
comes forward it turns out that you
cannot see the Rope with which he's
pulling under on the donkey and you say
well how did you do that by magic and
the farmer says well no see the Rope has
ultra-frequency you know high frequency
it has it's in the ultraviolet range and
that's why we you cannot see the road so
until you can see the Rope it's magic
and you say oh it was mass it was energy
it was force but as soon as you see the
Rope you say oh that's that's you know
simple he pulled on a rope and that's
how the he pulled those donkey forward
and what I'm saying is what we have to
do is make the invisible objects visible
if there is a magnet that attracts
another magnet there's a physical entity
between them you cannot use the word
energy you cannot use the word force
you're gonna use the word field you got
to use a physical object there's
something there that that we cannot seek
we cannot touch that's producing that
physical effect and until we make it
visible we won't understand we will not
have a physical interpretation of how
two magnets attract each other all right
incredibly offensive says how can you
say waves are concepts haven't haven't
you ever used a microwave or a radio
yeah I use a microwave because a
microwave is a physical object oh the
oven right but a wave is not a physical
object that you made people believe that
you know the flag is a physical object
not the waving of the flag water is a
physical object not the waves
Prussia you know that move along the
water wave there's no physical object
called wave you go to the hardware store
and you ask him for a rope they'll tell
you a rope ask him for a wave let's see
what they sell you ask him for a field
let's see what they sell you ask him for
energy let's see what he gives you all
right the UM Camarillo says is the rope
connected to time in any way time is not
a is not a word of science time is a
word of religion so we don't use that
word time for anything we have no need
for time because time only describes
energy only describes mass only
describes and science we do not describe
in science we explain you have to
explain a mechanism so we define you is
the word time I cannot attach anything
to time because I cannot attach anything
to love or to intelligence there's no
physical object called intelligence
there's no physical object called time
but we have been brain much so much with
these words that we treat them as
physical object
people think that energy is a physical
object and it turns into mass which is a
physical object and they're all concepts
mathematical abstractions all right but
I mean time has to exist in some way
even if it's not an object even if you
can't play with it in the universe
it has to be a proper description of
what happens when you move objects
doesn't it when you say that time exists
you have to define the word exist
because that makes a brighter your
argument what do you mean by exist and
I'm sure no one can even be no one has
done it in ten thousand years yeah it's
a very hard question what what does
exist mean in the context of time I
would say it is a it is a phenomenon
from which I can't see I can't see
something emerging from it but not in
the context of time what you have to
tell me is a definition that you can use
across the board you can use that I
would say them for three you can use for
everything for god I would say I cannot
I cannot construct a view of the
universe that doesn't invoke time and
some
there is this dimension across which we
are moving as 3d objects aren't we
but what are you using time for to
describe I mean wait a second yeah I
mean it is clearly a dimension of the
universe would you agree with that at
least no it's not a dimension that I
mentioned there's only three dimension
length width and height time is a
coordinate in fact it I think it's a
coordinate time is a number line time is
a number line absolutely I agree with
this because we're walking along it in a
unidirectional fashion time does not
have any importance in science because
time is only used to describe at first
it's an undefined word nobody has
defined the word time in ten thousand
years so they cannot use it until they
define it precisely I have defined time
but they got to read my book for that no
one has I find time in mathematical
physics no one has defined it but
assuming they did define it it's a
concept and it's an instead of it's not
as I mentioned it's not even a
coordinate all that time is is a number
line it doesn't have direction which
number lines don't have and it has
magnitude which is what number lines
have dimension is something else that I
mentioned has to have two properties
orthogonal T and direction and time has
neither one of those that's why time is
not a dimension
all right buddy Matic neat says Jeff
asked him about quantum and tongue and
single months do you have anything from
your theory on entanglement perfect like
I'll illustrate it for you okay there we
go I think what can I do this there we
go okay you see that now I'm gonna throw
the rope okay from my end from my end
it's twirling counterclockwise how about
from your end can you tell me from what
you're in what it's how it's turning
it's like a rotation Chuck
okay now I'm gonna turn my rope
clockwise how is it turning on your side
counterclockwise now you have a
definition of entanglement when you take
a reading at one end you're gonna have
the rope go clockwise the other and must
you cannot avoid going counterclockwise
when you turn the rope clockwise the
other end must turn counterclockwise
period better with entanglement very
easy stuff kids stuff baby stuff very
interesting because I was about to ask
more generally the rope has a structure
whereby if you take consecutive slices
of the rope the red and blue parts of it
are rotating what does it manifest
itself into in our universe if there are
ropes that do carry the the light signal
let me draw it here I'm gonna erase this
my old drawing so essentially you have
if you cut a rope yeah you have a red
part of the rope that will appear to be
a certain part and you have a blue part
of the rope that's what appear to be
another part now if I cut it at a
different place along the rope the the
blue part will be a little more rotated
as opposed to the red part being at
another place what depending on where I
am in the rope how does this manifest
itself in physics you go along the Rope
the rope is torque is structurally
torquing already it's already twisting
around each other the rope is DNA just
think of DNA what is DNA DNA is a rope
and that's that's where DNA got the idea
from light because light is already a
torsion if I take a cross-section of the
rope you know if I cut if I could cut it
you can't cut it but assuming I could
cut it what I would see is two threads
and yes anywhere along the rope you're
gonna have
you know a total switching of the sides
of one thread with respect to the other
there's going to be a torsion there a
structural torsion by the way also
rotates because when you pull on two
strands it torques the rope
automatically and that's what I'm saying
light is wonderful why am i sense ten
bucks he says Jeff thank you for writing
the revolutionary phenotype I have a
copy under the Christmas tree it's been
a great year for the public space and I
want to thank everyone for stopping by
hope all is well indeed I'm very proud
to have such a dedicated fan base who
have made my book rise to the top of the
Amazon biology section thank you so much
and keep buying it keep spreading it buy
a copy for your friends it's an
important book Carbon Muldoon says a
black hole is just a neutron star you
can't escape that is a good shower
thought martino Jaya Prada says
gentlemen is not energy ability to do
work and is not work is and is not work
force multiplied by distance as we all
learn in university so I think he's
getting at the definition of energy
right yeah but if you define a word it's
obviously not a physical objects in in
science in physics we do not define
objects we point to them you say table
you point and the electric the
extra-terrestrial understands the word
table and you can't do that with
concepts I cannot point to energy and
say this is energy I have to define the
term and that's why he's define it and
how to define it he defined it
mathematically defined it in terms of
work distance or whatever so so these
but again then you have all kinds of
energy you have potential energy and you
know dynamic energy you have all these
types of energies and then you have mr.
Fineman says oh by the way we don't know
what energy is so they're using a word
that they can't be fine and they're
using that to say
yeah now the conservation of energy and
energy turns into mass and and for
everything we put the word energy why
don't we put the word spirit I like the
word spirit not the word energy it's a
better word you know the spirit did this
I transferred the spirit is very the
better word than energy all right I
think that we are added to our the
confusion because I have another guest
who's coming in seven minutes he wants
to challenge me on my book and the
scientific theory on it perhaps I would
explore one last question with you
because when I look at your mother I
think it's a great model and it
stimulates the mind certainly to try to
understand the universe in simpler terms
and and I love it I love that a lot of
the characteristics that you identify
are they seem to be matching the
mathematics of a rope and but then I
would ask the question isn't it better
to just think of the universe as fields
as quantum fields and isn't your theory
ultimately isomorphic to quantum fields
whereby if I if I give a property to
every point in the universe as it's done
in quantum field theory there will be
the possibility of an establishment of a
rope-like entity between atoms between
different parts of the universe that
send either gravitational or light
signals or forces or whatever we want to
call them
ultimately is your theory making any
prediction that quantum field theory
wouldn't we don't make predictions first
of all we only explain that first answer
to that question we don't the
predictions is what they do in astrology
and mathematics we don't do predictions
that's the first one the second one is
that again until we know what a field is
we don't know what what we're talking
about and no one has been able to define
the word field except mr. Michael
Faraday and James Maxwell they defined
the word field but everybody forgot what
they said there is no such thing as a
field I cannot bring a standalone field
and put it in front of you I cannot take
the magnet out and leave the field and
say here's a field there's no physical
object called field the word
field means region around an object
where there are values that's what the
word field means and so then we have
that problem and no no so I don't use
the word field at all except to to
relate the rope to what mathematics has
its far uses the word field for so I'm
saying one when they say feel this is
what they're referring to in terms of
ropes when they say energy this is what
they're referring to in terms of the
rope model and so I make a that's the
only time I use the word energy or field
just to show what people are talking
about but in mathematics you know you
don't have a standalone field you don't
have standalone energy you don't have
stand-alone mass these are concepts and
people have turned them into objects and
they treat them as object and that's why
I'm saying every time you use the word
energy mass field just put the word
spirit and you'll be okay all right
well it was really a pleasure talking to
you I really love your defense of your
ID I may not I may not fully adhere to
it but I'm thinking there is a
geometrical thinking there that that
this theory stimulates inside me that
even if it was only to make me review
eventually some of my preconceived
notions from being being raised through
relativity and quantum physics and
Newton mechanics I think that it
certainly has a very stimulating effects
on the mind and even if it was just for
that it would certainly have a great
value I thank you so much for coming
tonight
thank you all right I have a great day